Dallas pastor Bishop TD jakes is sharing
an important message about the time it
takes to create change he is the senior
pastor at the potter's house which has
more than 30,000 members Bishop Jake's
spoke out on Friday real change comes in
process and comes in time and I think
we're at a turning point right now which
way that turn goes is up to you and I
and what we do with it and how we
respond to it Bishop Jake's joins us
only on CBS this morning Bishop it's
always good to see you I've heard it
described as a reckoning a watershed
moment a game-changer a tipping point we
just heard you say a turning point is a
word you use so how do we embrace this
moment and turn it into real change well
first of all I think that it is a
turning point because it is the
protesters are not all black or all
white the American community is all
marching in fact the global community is
marching in an unprecedented way that is
indicative of the fact that that we have
been heard and somebody gets it but what
we really must focus on is moving from
protesting to policy you can only
protest so long and protesting is great
and getting attention and it has gotten
attention around the world which is very
important but if that protesting doesn't
turn into policy at the end of the day
we will go back to normalcy we've seen
this too many times before yeah I know
people keep saying we've heard this song
before what's going to be different and
I keep saying listen I know it's about
race black and white but I also see that
it's about humanity do you see it as
being bigger than black and white as
well I think it is being about black and
white but it ultimately becomes about
right and wrong and people begin to
understand that what they saw the
atrocities that they saw executed on
George Lloyd and were so reprehensible
that it was hard to deny that this
wrong but that is just a tip of the
iceberg had it not been for the click of
a camera we would never even know what
happened the records were falsified
there was all types of corruption in the
process there's a discrepancy in the
autopsies it just shows that there is a
system that condones and supports and
there is a fraternity in this debauchery
that has to be dealt with it has to be
cleaned out from the root up if we don't
clean it out from the root up and we
just pick a few leaves off the tree
we're gonna be back here again in a few
months I want to talk to you about the
looting and some people are calling it
rioting people say listen use the word
demonstration I've heard you say don't
let that be a distraction on what we
should focus on anytime you have a
massive crowd of this magnitude and
anybody can walkie and in an America
walk up in anybody can participate it is
hard to regulate that kind of behavior
but we cannot let the misdeeds and the
inappropriate deeds of a few distract us
from the calls for which we're out there
and I think when we do that we start
trying to treat the symptoms but we
don't try to fix the infection and I
think we have to bypass the symptoms and
and grappling with the symptoms and fix
the infection we need these other police
officers to be arrested and we need to
handle those issues we need to set up a
council to develop a policy that is
comprehensive throughout all police
departments and we need to regulate it
and about financial aid to police
departments and do not live up to those
regulations we need substantive change
and we cannot be distracted by a few
vigilantes that come in and distort the
essence of why people are there marching
in the first
yeah you know people keep saying now is
a time for healing let's come together
but I've heard you say maybe people
aren't ready to heal at this particular
point in time what do you mean by that
there's no way we can have healing it's
like opening up somebody in the middle
of the surgery and say you know let's
heal while they're still bleeding it's
not healing that we're after it's change
that we're after if we need to reset the
bone let's do it now while everything is
open and we need to remove the cancer
let's remove it now but you don't want
to heal in the middle of a surgery we
want to heal when things are right and I
think that our rush to get back to
normalcy has caused us to over and over
again be unproductive in bringing about
long-term systemic changes that are
actionable that are satisfying and that
causes America to live up to its Creed
and its highest ideals we've got the
right ideals we just don't live up to
them in Bishop Jake's you know this is
probably the first week in a long time
that we haven't really led with the
Kovach story all of this is happening
too in the middle of a Kovach pandemic
what are your thoughts on that well
that's the tragedy about this situation
we have three crises going on
simultaneously I don't think we have
ever in the history of this country had
three of this magnitude we have an
economic pandemic we have a
physiological health pandemic and then
we have a sociological pandemic going on
all at the same time and it has reached
global proportions you can't have a
problem in America and either one of the
Front's that does not affect the entire
globe and we have all of them going on
simultaneously and I have to admit this
is a dangerous time for our country
because of the convergence of those
three different issues of coalescing at
the same time it's a very dangerous time
because we have enemies and we have
external enemies that seek to exploit
these off
and we have to be all the more vigilant
to be watchful because we are quite
vulnerable right now
we have unrest in every area of our
government and every area of our being
and we do not have the Solidarity that
we need to be the country that is able
to defend itself and defend our allies
because we are distracted by internal
corruption which is is the story of the
fall of the Roman Empire I want to get
your take on this you know Donald Trump
went to church stood in front of her
church and held a Bible and Reverend
William barber who I know you know and a
Christian preacher Jonathan Wilson Hart
Gross said the president's use of the
Bible was obscene he should try reading
the words inside now to be honest I
don't know whether the president reads a
Bible or not but I know you do so I
would like to know what was your take
when you saw that I think you know one
of the things that I think it's
important to realize that America is a
country that has a lot of religions now
I am a Christian I support Christianity
but by the same token we need to have a
government that expresses impartiality
to all the other schools of thought that
exist in the world when people want to
hear about theology they come to church
when they want to hear about policy they
go to the White House the convergence of
those two have to be carefully handled
I'm not saying that one can affect the
other but we have to be very very
careful that we don't pollute or
download the very idea of democracy the
very idea of a republic that embraces an
overarching umbrella that allows us to
have the freedom of religion and the
freedom of choice and the freedom to
believe will not believe and sometimes
in the process of expressing your
personal faith out of all question his
faith I think it leaves a message to
people who have other belief systems
that they might be bias in some way and
then it sounds like a dog whistle to the
base to be quite candid and that's
what we need right now we don't need to
collect the base we need to collect the
country the whole country
the Jews atheists agnostics of Muslims
it's gonna take the whole country coming
together because the marching in the
street is proof that people who are
marginalized eventually erupt and so
right now our focus cannot be on the
nuances of our own individual beliefs so
I'll share those beliefs I'm whole heart
in their question I love the faith I
love the Bible I love the Word of God
but right now what we need as a country
is to pull everybody black white young
Oh
Jews Gentiles we're all types of people
bring them together right so that we can
live up to what the idea is all about
alright Bishop yes your message stay
focused people stay focused thank you
very much Bishop TD jakes always good to
see you